[Musique]
on connaissait le distributeur de café
ou de confiserie un entrepreneur a
carrément inventé un supermarché
automatique avec 150 produits différents
ça va du sandwich à la boisson en
passant par le papier et ça fonctionne
il a commencé avec un supermarché
automatique il en a désormais 3 le
reportage de théophile mba cas échéant
les griefs
c'est une rue très passante de bourges
un impératif pour faire fructifier ce
commerce et faire découvrir la dernière
épicerie automatique au grand public
c'est pratique quand on est les magasins
sont fermés tout comme ça des fois on
peut servir pour le prends du beurre du
lait c'est vrai que c'est pratique et
c'est moins cher
il n'y a pas de files d'attentes c'est
très fluide
donc voilà il ya beaucoup de choix moi
je trouve que c'est bien ça permet
d'avoir de la nourriture qu'elle
n'importe quelle heure du jour ou de la
nuit quoi sébastien du tu n'es pas un
novice dans la profession c'est un
ancien gérant de boutique de location de
films avant que ce commerce ne périclite
l'homme semble avoir trouvé le filon
pour preuve il est à la tête des trois
supermarchés automatique à bourges
pourquoi supermarché automatique
pour répondre à une demande de la
clientèle de nocturne en faute pour
avoir un service 24 heures sur 24
nous avons un magasin principal sur
lequel nous sommes livrés dans une
chambre froide et ensuite je ventile sur
les autres magasins de la ville la
marchandise et les prix sont définies
comment les prises sont définis donc
nous sommes sous une licence de marque
donc nous avons un concept et c'est eux
qui nous préconise les prix de revente
afin d'avoir une marche suffisant pour
pouvoir amortir l'ensemble des
investissements pour éviter la
concurrence
il a ouvert ce troisième magasin et gère
seul l'ensemble des supermarchés
automatique le chiffre d'affaires passe
de 5000 euros par magasin en hiver à
10000 euros par magasin
en haute saison juin juillet et août
dernière innovation le distributeur de
baguette tradition à proximité de la
gare
nous avions une boulangerie à côté mais
elle est fermée depuis deux ans et je
sais qu'elle ne reniera pas donc pour
apporter un service supplémentaire sur
le pour le quartier et attiré un peu
plus de clientèle sur le site nous avait
pensé à mettre dix lutteurs de baguettes
20 à 30 baguette en moyenne par jour
autant dire des ventes correctes
et l'un des produits préférés des
français le miel est traditionnellement
produit dans le gâtinais nous y sommes à
villemandeur g culturel bonjour syrie
lauverjat vous êtes à la tête de cette
pme qui conditionne de miel l'avant de
mettre en pot vous le préparez on le
prépare oui alors qu'est-ce qui va se
faire alors là vous avez la chance
d'avoir un miel de fleurs français voilà
et comme alors nous on a un principe
c'est que on ne
on ne chauffe pas de miel donc le moins
possible dans tous les cas et là on a on
a investi dans du matériel qui permet de
défi j'ai à froid qu'est ce que ça
change au niveau gustatif
c'est surtout qu'est-ce que ça ne change
pas puisque en fait là donc nous notre
principe premier de faire en sorte que
le consommateur puisse retrouver
exactement le miel tel qu'il a été
récoltée par l'apiculteur et là vous
voyez donc on a reçus le fut la part du
de l'apiculteur en l'état voilà il est
propre
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle donc
on peut on peut le travailler de cette
façon est donc là on va le on va
pourrait dire l'assouplir pour après
pouvoir le mettre en pot tout simplement
des ports vous reproduisez combien
chaque année chaque vol on est à peu
près sûr 2 millions de pots donc à
l'année quand on est
une entreprise de 27 salariés tout de
même des clients qui sont parfois des
grandes enseignes de supermarchés c'est
facile de se positionner et en ayant une
exigence de production comme la vôtre
alors non c'est pas facile de se
positionner puisqu'en fait il ya une
mamie donc de la part de certains
concurrents et notamment sur les miels
d'assemblage donc on va retrouver donc
on va toucher miel c'est hors cee c'est
l'assemblage de 5 à 7 voire 8 miel
différents donc à contres ou voir donc
m sur le marché des miels qui sont notre
cher bon nous on est enrichissante donc
on à du miel de soleil l'a également
aussi du miel de maquis corse
juste derrière on a un miel de champagne
on a donc aussi à miel de bruyère
il vous coûte cher c'est miel français
on sait qu'ils sont de plus en plus rare
dans les rayons comme vous savez la
production française a baissé et pour
pouvoir compenser le prix de le prix du
miel français à augmenter ses coûts de
combien paraphe par rapport à miel
je vais vous parler de mon prix d'achat
par exemple amiel d'ukrainiens donc mis
à l'ukrainien et miel de chine amiel
d'argentine sur le marché ça peut
s'acheter deux euros du kilo à miel en
miel de fleurs donc à miel de fleurs
européen on va être plutôt sur 3 euros 3
euros 50
amiel de france on va être surtout sur 5
euros et nous au travail sur certains
projets en ce moment qui vont nous
permettre de valoriser jusqu'à 6 euros
est ce qu'il fait cette différence de
prix bas déjà un peu la rareté parce que
c'est vrai que mon en trente ans on est
passé de 40 mille tonnes à 20 mille
tonnes donc voire même encore un peu
moins en ce moment les en fonction des
années entre 8 et 16 mille tonnes donc
de production de biens en france et
c'est ça qui fait que donc le prix à le
prix augmentent et nous on est convaincu
que plus la bei a va être dans un
environnement sain en biodiversité plus
donc elle va pouvoir produire un peu
plus et plus elle va donc permettre à
l'apiculteur de faire correctement son
métier maintien des pots de miel
commercialisé par cooker miel sont issus
de l'agriculture biologique
c'est à la fois une volonté du dirigeant
est une tendance du marché cet été
l'entreprise va encore plus loin en
reversant une partie du prix de vente de
simmel français au fonds de protection
des abeilles